what's going on everyone i want to share
a quick lesson that i had
yesterday with my 18 year old neighbor
uh who's going through his
entrepreneurial journey and this is a
lot of fun for me because
uh he's at ground zero so i'm hearing
you know the anxieties and the worries
and the false beliefs kind of come up as
they go and i get to
you know confront them and kind of ask
good questions and so
uh kind of the lesson or the theme of
yesterday uh was around
volume and luck right and so
one of the key differences that i see
with people who are successful and do
grow and do scale
is that they have a firm understanding
of probability all right and what that
means is chance what's the percentage
likelihood that something happens
right if you want to be an investor
right
then you have to calculate the the risk
associated with an investment that's a
probability outcome
if you are a business owner right you
have to
gamble on marketing and assess the
probability that you'll get a return on
that investment
right and what's interesting is that
volume negates luck all right so if you
can put that in your brain
volume negates luck and so
luck is a word that people who don't
understand probability use
as as a space filler but if i were to
say hey for every uh you know 100
000 emails i send i get 1 000 back and
from
1 000 that i get back i know that i'm
going to close
500 of those people on a deal that's not
realistic math i would probably
close a lot more than that but the point
is um but if i if i explain that math to
you
you probably i'd be like is that luck
that i closed 500 deals
you'd probably be like no that's just
probability
that's just i know that if i reach this
many people
the probability that there is one person
who's interested in the in the services
that i have
is high right and the thing is is that
if you do enough
volume you can negate luck
all right you can also negate skill
which is a byproduct of the volume all
right so let me let me
let me dive into that let me unpack that
for a second
so let's say you suck right because
you're brand new and of course you would
suck
because why would you be good because
you've never done this before whatever
it is
right and so this is like the
conversation i'm having with my neighbor
you can imagine me as like
like coaching at 18 year old get him
like of course you suck
you're supposed to suck you're not
supposed to be good right and the thing
is is like because of social media
because of instagram because of all
these things
everyone especially you know the guys
who are younger right now and
maybe it's the same for guys who are in
their 30s whatever is that they just
immediately assume they should be a
millionaire the first year
right it's just like i should be a
millionaire why am i not a millionaire
right
and so that's what stops 99 of people
from being successful because
they're unwilling to suck right and it
hurts their ego too much
to be bad and so then they say ah this
isn't for me
right and so anyways back to the point
of the volume versus you know negating
the luck in the skill component
is that let's say the normal numbers
let's say i was i was coaching him on
on cold calling right cause that's what
he's doing right now and i said listen
it's gonna take
you know it should take you about a
thousand cold calls to get
you know one deal right and let's say he
comes to me and he says well i've done
five thousand
right i'm like okay and
so i don't have a deal i'm like and
you suck of course you don't have a deal
you've never done this before
do another five thousand because the
thing is eventually
you will it will be unreasonable for you
to suck anymore
right it would be unreasonable for you
to not have found one person
if you do this for a straight year and
i'm trying to paint this longer picture
for him
a year and i know when you're 18 a year
sounds like forever but like
a year if you did this for five years if
you did nothing but cold call for five
years
do you think you would be good at cold
calling he was like
yeah probably i was like do you feel
like you're much better now than you
were one month ago when you started this
he was like oh
i'm like night and day better like i can
get past you know i can open now i can
have conversation i was getting hung up
on
i was like right and so you have this
binary measure of progress which is
i either closed the sale or i didn't
close the sale when in reality there's
tons of bricks on the bridge
on the way to getting the first dollar
over right and the first deal the first
dollar independent of whatever you're
doing is the always the hardest one
and it's because you have to learn a lot
of little skills
before you get the big payoff right and
most people
learn one skill or don't learn a skill
and then think up
this isn't for me right and so i told
him
that the only way that i would give him
my blessing for him to quit
is if the enti he could convince me that
the entire industry of wholesaling real
estate had disappeared
if you can convince me that the entire
industry of wholesaling real estate has
disappeared
you will have my blessing to quit and
obviously that's not going to happen
because people
have been making money in whole
wholesaling real estate for a long time
right there's always going to be
inefficiencies in marketplaces between
buyers and sellers
right unless some magical technology
comes through which it might in 10 years
who knows
but for right now it exists and so i
said the only thing
that separates you from what you want is
skill
and the only way to acquire that skill
is volume
right and the thing is is when you have
enough skill you get luckier
right you don't need to do 10 000 calls
to get that one deal
because honestly maybe in the beginning
that is that is
that is the biggest lay down person
you'll ever have but then it gives you
conviction that it can happen
right and so um the more volume you do
the better you get
and therefore the luckier you become but
the big picture is that
people who invest people who who do
business at larger scale
just understand probability right they
understand
that there is a percentage now what's
what's the the worst thing that can
happen
is let's say his this is this is a fun
scenario to think about
is let's say his first day he gets on
the phone
and he somehow closes the deal right and
that one deal may have been that one
deal out of 10 000
that if he had started at the other end
of the call list it might have taken him
a month to get there
but he just happens to do it first how
much do you think that messes him up
a ton maybe maybe or probably even more
than working really hard to get there
and so i don't know about you but i feel
like i've definitely had occasions where
i've
lucked out and then i start questioning
myself what am i doing different what am
i doing different you might not be doing
anything different
you might have just hit the hit the gold
nugget way too early in the cycle
and now you got to sift through a lot
more no's to get to your next one you
might have to sift through twice as many
notes as normal because you gotta
you gotta account for the nose from the
first one that you never actually hit
right
and so anyways as i'm walking him
through this right
it just reminded me of how when people
are starting out they don't understand
the
the concept of large numbers right if
you want to become lucky if you want to
have probability on your side you simply
increase n increase the number increase
the volume
and eventually you will strike gold and
the thing is is that most people just
literally don't go long enough
um he honestly was doing the the little
system that he's that he's purchased
the wrong way up until like a week ago
and so i was like cool well your first
three weeks are wasted that you weren't
doing it the right way
right you've now officially been doing
this for seven days right do you feel
like it's unreasonable
like do you feel like it'd be reasonable
for you to have a top one percent income
in the united states after one month of
learning a new skill
he was like no and i was like then stop
believing you should
i was like if you do this for four years
because he's not right now he's pushing
off college to do this
i was like if you do this for four
straight years i was like do you think
it would be reasonable that you'd be
able to close
one deal a month by the end of that and
he was like yeah and i was like cool
then you're already twice
as wealthy as the average college person
who would be leaving
right except you have four more years of
experience than they do and so i'm
trying to like paint these paint
just give him a different frame of
seeing success and seeing the work
that's required to get there
and i was like what happens if what
happens if in six years when you're 24
what happens if in six years 24 and
you're not a millionaire yet what
happens that
he was like i mean i'd be you know i was
like what you'd be disappointed you're
not a millionaire at 24.
come on man the thing is is he might
actually be
right if he actually sticks with it for
six straight years but most people end
up hopping
and and always doing these half-built
bridges where they they learn two three
four of the skills but there's ten that
they have to learn
and they say this isn't for me and they
jump to another one they start building
a new bridge
right when the reality is you just have
to keep laying the bricks keep playing
the bricks keep laying the bricks all
the way across the bridge from where you
are to where you want to be
and then the first dollar walks across
and it takes a lot of time to put those
bricks in place and to figure out
which brick you're missing and the only
way to do it is more
and that is how you'll get better at the
skill that gets the dollar across the
bridge
so anyways more more more sagas of my 18
year old
workout afternoon uh lessons i hope you
enjoy this
uh if you do you know subscribe like
comment all that kind of good stuff
uh and i'll see you in the next video